a bunch of questions a lot of people
have gone to space the last few years
and there's a level of interest in you
know blue origin and everything that's
been going on but the level of interest
on your trip to space was another level
in terms of the media interest in terms
of it being a worldwide story were you
aware when you were doing this
totally not on the contrary
the name of the gentleman who started
all jason ehrlich who a couple of years
ago said you know
blue origin is going to go up and you
should go up and i don't know you don't
want me to go up there yeah you know and
make a story now
nobody's interested jason so two years
ago he made the call and we went up to
uh seattle
and met with jeff bezos who turns out is
a star trek uh
not even a fan a passionate
uh observer and in the lobby of uh
amazon
uh are these uh are the artifacts uh the
the spaceship the
the the
the the enterprise and other things all
under glass all through the lobby and we
took pictures beside it and i thought
that's really strange you know this man
so sophisticated and knowledgeable he's
all involved in like you are with the
with the with the show
uh and then uh coveted and it was uh
they stopped doing it and i said to
jason see i told you and then uh last
year
uh we read that blue is going up and j
and jeff bezos is going to do it oh well
maybe jeff bezos will pick you and uh he
picks his brother he picks a a a lady
with gray hair and he picks a young man
who hasn't got gray hair and and they go
up and i said you see jason i joined
nobody and then they asked me for the
second voyage and i said i'm not going
to go up in the second point you know
that's what getting the vice president
and when you want the president
it's not going to work and uh he's no
the people are not and then i thought
why why don't i just go for the thrill
of it
just to go into space as uncomfortable
as it's going to be and
i love to stay at home now i'm i'm a
stay-at-homer i used to roam all over
the globe and now i love my home i love
my dogs and i want to stay home and i
don't want to i'd like to talk to you
from the comfort of my home i'm loving
this
no let's go okay so i go thinking it's
going to be innocuous
and it turns out to be trending
worldwide and i was shocked
absolutely shocked i thought nobody
would notice and here it is
oh it ever my friends in brazil and they
were talking to me about it i mean it
was everywhere
um one of the things that uh so blue
origin obviously has this amazing group
of people that are working together to
get everyone to space but i would
imagine like 99 of the people that work
there were inspired by star trek and
were inspired by science fiction and
hollywood and books to um to to do what
they do
what does it mean to you actually
because i would imagine everyone you met
at blue origin wanted a picture with you
and i mentioned
and what you said to begin with the
people there at blue origin
everybody i met are quality people i
mean they're they're imbued with a
passion
you know bezos passion
is
to get
polluting industry up into the uh up
into the uh space up into i think
geocentric
orbit
so that
an electrical company burning whatever
they're burning it doesn't matter
because it's way in space
uh excuse the expression beams down the
electricity to read a thing here and
spreads the the juice out
um
mechanic the mechanics are all there
all we have to do is get
industry
up there buildings engines uh
fuel
and you could pollute up there that's
his dream
and uh
i came back and i think that's a great
idea how much more practical for the
moment to save the world
it is then flying
into some esoteric place like mars
and looking at mars and saying oh
here we are now we fly back hopefully
you know a year and a half
yeah that that voyage is like it's it's
hard to put your head around what that
voyage will do and what it would take to
get to mars exactly you know um have you
actually looked at the footage of you
going have you have you watched the
footage and what's been you
no nothing i i have not i've heard about
it i saw an er excerpt but i know
nothing
i'm curious if you could talk about what
are you most excited for people to see
actually in the documentary
well the documentary which is uh going
to be shown on uh december 15th
on uh
on amazon prime
i i'm curious i i i
i may have suggested
it's in my mind i suggested shooting a
documentary and organized the
documentary uh and we
and and from what i remember uh amazon
um
didn't think about it or
had no concept and we were shooting
me
uh with a with an iphone a lot of
documentaries have been made with an
iphone but there's a lot of footage in
this documentary that's on i mean it's a
great apple
advertising because a lot of this was
done on the camera of an iphone of a
more recent iphone
and then
my memory is that
amazon then came in with three cameras
after a while and they started shooting
everything and now we had a documentary
then i sat down with jeff
for uh
two times for a couple of hours each
time and in effect interviewed him
so this footage of jeff bezos and myself
talking and
in this talk show i have which is uh
called i don't understand uh are things
i don't understand which is everything
so i i have this talk show that's that's
monumental in my mind about talking
about anything how to write an opera uh
what's uh you know uh what's psycho says
but
so i'm interviewing jeff basis
and and this
man this man of
this man has made
this enormous company and that's no
accident
reveals something of himself
and
and it's uh
tremendously interesting as far as i'm
concerned uh of mr bezos uh
letting himself
uh
loose if you will for a few moments
well i'm curious obviously i know what
it's like to prepare to interview
someone what is it like for you when you
are getting ready to interview one of
the world's richest men and arguably one
of the most powerful
yeah and i don't think you'd argue that
it certainly is
um
you know i i i've got uh a lady coming
on next week for uh i do about four or
five
interviews in a day and then do two days
and i got about 10 i bank about 10
interviews in a couple of days
and so it's difficult to prepare
for those interviews uh in any depth so
i get first
uh i've made many suggestions of who i'd
like to talk to or the subject of the
talk to and this wonderful organization
uh
at uh at aura tv uh does the background
so they'll hand me people and they'll
say this is somebody oh that's great and
then i'll read something of their
background and something of the
questions and i've got an interest in
the subject and
i just plunge into the interview without
any
you know without a lot of preparation
although there's one lady i'm going to
talk to about depression and and um
and uh and uh uh
uh
uh uh
looking into nature um i'm trying to
think of the term
i've read the book so i am in the middle
of doing both preparing
and not preparing so i can wander into
an interview and just go ramble along
the the pathways of the interview and
when you reach a moment of interest when
that word comes out that why did you
choose that word and where and we go
along
uh interesting
subject matters in a in an interview
that never were thought of
by the researchers or by the interviewee
themselves so that's what happened with
jeff i would just started talking to him
and about his background and what he
wants to do and
became a full-fledged really
i think a great interview they said he
had never opened up like that
to other people you know
we
in the public eye are always on guard uh
to not to say something that could be
interpreted as nasty or or take a word
out of context and all that kind of
thing so i had a wonderful time with mr
bezos
um
and i knew nothing
what's funny is of all the people that
have interviewed him you must have been
the one that he it meant the most to him
because of his history
that is so uh observant of you i think
that's right because
i
did not intend any harm i'm not after a
a a a uh a uh banner uh i was just after
curiosity of a man who's lived uh is
living a full life and uh i wanna know a
little bit about it and i don't wanna
harm him whereas journalists sometimes
wanna get something sensational
um i i am so curious i myself
am nervous to go to space because of i
grew up and i saw the challenge no no no
no because you exactly because you could
die well when could you
do you remember the footage on the
hindenburg
oh a hundred percent yeah so what was
burning on the hindenburg the fuel
the hydrogen yeah you know what they're
putting into the rocket that i sat on
hydrogen
it could burn in fact at the top of the
gantry
there's a cement room oh cement a foot
thick with a big door that yeah and you
push the door and it locks airtight
in case anything goes wrong you run into
that into that safe room
what do you mean anything can go wrong
what's going to go wrong
i'm very curious so myself i when i was
a kid i saw the challenger explode and
it permanently changed
my perception i mean i now it was it was
easy to realize going to space is very
dangerous so for you i am so curious was
there any point of this that you're like
this i mean i mean i don't want to say
it like this
the gantry is right up against the the
the rocket and so you get in and go and
you lie down you've been in a simulation
but now it's for real and then the the
people say now look
we're going to close the doors
and the gantry is there for a few
minutes
until the gantry leaves if you scream i
got to get out of here i suppose they
were looking at people in my panic we'll
get you out
but once the gantry leaves everybody
you can't get out
so until that moment you think well i
can always get out i go oh it's cleaving
i can't get out now
suddenly the reality is in your lap
yeah so my my question for you is did
you ever debate
at any point saying i'm a little too
scared to do this you know that i'm this
i was faced with you know i mean i was i
i had all those images you're talking
about were in my mind you know
uh
the
explosion uh
of the explorer was because the o-rings
were cold and and there was this
argument of whether you know they got to
make their schedule and okay we can do
it but even though it's a little cold
and they had an argument the engineers
as you may remember discussing now we
shouldn't go yes so we got to go we got
to go
and so they went
against some of the people's judgment
and they went one of the reasons they
went was we got this overwhelming
schedule and it's okay we'll go and
we'll get it it's it it'll hold it'll be
agreed fine well it wasn't
and that's called human error
and we're we're
we're
prone
well how many seven billion people on
the earth eight million billion people
on the earth where it got eight billion
possibilities of human error yeah it's
it's so frustrating um for the there's
going to be the
99.99 keep on going percent of the human
population will never get to experience
what you experienced right um
what do you really want to what do you
want to tell people about the trip and
what you experienced
i've got an album out there called bill
and i worked with two gentlemen
a wonderful poet for a lyricist and
wonderful gentleman for music and bill
has received incredible notices and
there's a song on bill called so far
from the moon when i was destitute and i
was watching the guys walk on the moon
and and these two guys
dan miller and
rob the poet and i had dinner the monday
before i was leaving for the desert and
we said you know we got to write a song
about space we're jotting down notes
what it's going to be like
and then i leave and i go to the desert
and i
practice and practice and finally we go
up and then when i came down one of the
first calls i made was to my two friends
and i said you know the thing we were
talking about sunday about writing notes
about what space is going to be like
forget about it it has nothing to do
with anything and i told them what i
experienced which was
i saw the beauty of earth i saw the
deadliness of space and
and what i saw most of all
it's so easy to say oh we're a little
bit you know we got this little rocky
planet in the middle of a mediocre sun
and a
less than unusual
galaxy
it's one thing to say this
but it's another to look at it to see it
to see
how
incredibly small the earth is the earth
is tiny
tiny
i could see the beginnings of the
curvature of the earth from where i was
the curvature so those lines end
i could see i could see the beginning of
the ending of the lines that's what
we're living on i've hitchhiked i've
i've driven across this country i've
done i've crossed this country
innumerable times on a motorcycle last
the roads go on endlessly endlessly
there's no end to these roads it seems
so big
it's not
it's this little tiny rocky
insignificant
thing
in the middle of nowhere this it's
you couldn't find us and we had signals
emanating all over the earth you
couldn't find us we're so small
we're insignificant
and you and i
are these little
we're with it's smaller than ants we're
smaller than ants on the earth
we occupy
less space
uh
in in contrast to the earth
so we're
insignificant
in an insignificant planet
and the only significance that i
observed and this is the change
the only
thing that i noted with pride
was that
we insignificant beings
are observing
how insignificant we are
and that's what i brought home
yeah also you got to see what the
atmosphere looks like which is paper
thin
yeah i mean practically speaking is what
is it 50 miles of air uh but only about
uh
two miles is useful it has enough oxygen
for us to live and so there's 48 miles
of air that is useless and then there's
nothing i mean 48 50 miles
you can walk there you can bicycle that
i know
and that's air that's what we're
breathing and that's what we're
polluting
that we're throwing up
garbage into the air and people are
arguing about it i mean what is the
argument you idiots
it's like it's like
going into quicksand and you're up to
hearing the quicksand you're saying you
know they'll miss me there'll be a
bottom there's a bottom here
and you somewhere
it makes me insane and i think that the
old saying yeah it may i i wish that all
the people that were in control could
see the fred the the fragile nature of
what of our planet and
that's the title of this song that we
did write that is going into the next
album so fragile so blue
uh
it's going to be
terrific and that's what i brought back
that i have to ask what change that's
the change i have to stop there even
though i could ask you an hour more
worth of questions i am just going to
say it was great watching you go to
space i cannot wait to watch the full
documentary and um i just thank you so
much for your time and for all of your
work uh i just say thank you
thank you thank you for saying that
you